That's a woman, by the way. This is a
woman. Yeah.
They just kicked her.
Chilleit from Black Resin. I do
bodybuilding. I do boxing. I do
calisthenics. I run out of energy. I get
fatigued. Chiligit is a natural
substance found in the Himalayas. It's
created by centuries of grass and
organisms decomposing into a thick black
goo which makes it very potent. As you
can see, it's like a tartike product.
You just get a little bit of this and
put it in your smoothies, milk, other
products inshallah. If the taste is too
strong for you guys, energy levels up
inshallah. And also, there is some
studies that show it boosts
testosterone, even helps the respiratory
system as well. Buy yours now, brothers
and sisters. Go to the description box
in use my discount code and let's see
stronger, better, more focused Muslim
men who are serving the Lord and their
families and their wives and their
children. Brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well.
Inshallah, we are back with another
reaction
video. I'm going to react to that. The
stronger you try to look, the weaker you
are. Also reaction video to your fake
muscles. I think you have your steroid
muscles. Your pumped up muscles.
Okay. So, talking about uh being a man,
obviously it reminds me of myself. I'm
talking about No, no.
Okay. I want you to watch this video.
Something bereft of a quality cannot
produce. I don't know what he said, but
you spoke out. Something that doesn't
have something can't give it.
Okay. Okay. Watch this video. Yeah. And
I want your thoughts of it. Okay. Cuz we
know the Zionist regime is known to
attack men and women. Um well, women and
children, should we say, for that
matter. And I want you to tell me where
which country this happened in. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
That's a woman, by the way. This is a
woman.
They just kicked her. Why though? I
don't know.
They kicked there again.
[Music]
So, I mean, what do you make out of? And
by the way, would you do you know where
this happened? New York.
It says there, but when I watched it, I
actually thought this is Israel. I could
not believe this was happening in New
York, bro. Do you know what is the worst
thing about this thing is that there was
not the fact, okay, you've got a whole
group of mob of men. Yeah. That that are
just kind of Why would they find that
this is an appropriate action? Number
one. Yeah. But worse than that, why is
there only one police officer? Yes. You
know, if it was a Zionist protest, there
would be like a whole army of police
officers protecting her, let alone one
Zionist woman and stuff. Number three,
this dispels this idea that these
Zionists are peaceloving people and it's
the pro Palestinian people that are
creating problems and are violent in in
protest, we know for a fact had this
been pro Palestinian uh protest and and
this would this was a Jewish woman. By
the way, can you imagine? By the way, I
think she's a Jewish woman. Yeah.
Apparently, she is Jewish herself. Yeah.
Yeah. But so can you imagine if this was
like the the roles have been reversed
here. Oh my gosh. Imagine like imagine
hundreds of Muslim men in their attire
you th or whatever you want to call it
kicking a bro bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro it would be to be honest
though I surprised cuz like why is this
happening in New York? Yeah. I mean this
would never happen in London. No let's
be honest if if we one kind of person
like that and then being pushed like
that it would never happen. It shows you
that that I mean I mean I know that New
York has done some excellent things but
we need to be careful here as well you
know don't let these mobsters you know
do this to people but at the end of the
day pro Palestinian people. Yeah exactly
and the thing is we don't know they they
I think they're in the assumption she's
pro Palestinian or whatever for that
matter. Um the issue here is that these
Zionist it's I mean you can't make this
up. I don't know why I'm just shocked
like I believe their greatest asset
these ionists is their confidence and I
believe it's their greatness weakness
and their end because they have this
overconfidence and it's as if bro the
way they're moving from Israel to here
and around the world they actually think
they're untouchable they actually and
and that is a person's greatest downfall
when you think that you are untouchable
but it's not just that I mean let's look
at the facts of the matter right Israel
is a country with one of the most
advanced armies in the Middle East it
has some of the those technologically,
you know, uh, important instruments that
have been created in the in the last
century, whatever. Yeah. And they're
struggling with the militant group. I've
just I've just been watching, um, you
know, Al Jazzer Arabic. Yeah. And Alazer
Arabic, you see videos of Hamas
literally sniping. I don't know if Have
you seen this? Have you seen the one
where they've been ambushed where they
went upstairs and start crying?
No, but just re I'm talking about after
all that's happened and now like even
now I've seen just videos recently
literally snipers killing them, rocket
launcher hitting them, bro. I mean, so
you guys are acting as if you're
untouchables. Yeah. And you are
struggling with a militant group which
doesn't have any tanks, which doesn't
have any drones and they operate on the
ground. Yeah. Maybe one or two drones
that they've done. They operate on the
ground. They don't even have an airport.
Yeah. Okay. and and you're struggling.
It's been so long you can't even you
have to negotiate with them. Yeah. This
is the position that you're in. And and
they're saying that the numbers of Hamas
members have increased and and to me
it's just like I don't know what like I
don't know what to make out of it. But
the whole world has woken up and there
was one of their I don't know who it was
he came he was like we're losing the war
in in in the media like like on the what
did he say bro? Um that guy who came up
the digital war. Yeah. He said we're
losing the digital war. He goes we've
got Mark Zuckerbergs and this that he
even made statement he even made a
statement close to the Jews run the
media or something along those he
literally said I was shocked when he
said that actually he said it was and
he's saying that we are losing this war
and they are losing it on all grounds
and this behavior is further showing I
mean I've seen a massive shift in their
absolutely but it also accentuates a
stereotype which is that these guys are
cowards they only operate they only act
like this when they're in groups exactly
when Basically, it's the whole idea.
It's like unless we have a complete
advantage. We're not going to engage in
conflict. Exactly. And you know, and
this is what the Quran says about those
particular guys that were trying to
attack those Jews, those particular
Jews, not just generalize all the Jews,
just in case anyone's watching and you
know this and that. But at the time of
the prophet Muhammad
[Music]
wasallam that they won't fight you. They
will not fight you to altogether unless
okay unless they are behind walls
fortified towers or fortified towers.
And but then do you know what it says
which is interesting followup of
this that they actually have internal
conflict with each other. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That you think that they are all
together. You think that they have one
united
front. Actually they are completely
disunited. There are people that don't
understand that have no understanding.
So we're seeing history repeat itself
here. Yeah. Okay. And we're seeing the
same kind of animosity presented to the
Palestinian people and the Muslim people
in general. And we're seeing the same
kind of stereotypes being accentuated
time and time again. You have a people
here that are not willing to engage in
conflict with a equal enemy. Yeah.
That's all it is. You have to have an
advantage or someone could argue well
Israel's uh fought, you know, the Arab
states before and stuff. Yeah. But only
with the backing of the United States of
America. Yeah. Exactly. And and those
Arab nations fought for for for
nationalism, not for Exactly. Yeah. And
and they deserve humility. I'll be
honest with you. Absolutely. If you're
going to fought for your Arab security.
Yeah. Yeah. When it was Arab pan Arabism
50s and 60s. Exactly. Allah will
humiliate you at the end of True. Yeah.
It's like that. And I mean, you've seen
again, guys. And we just want to thank
the Zionists again. We could have not
done it without you guys. Just be
yourselves and the whole world sees.
Yeah. Yeah. All you got to do is just be
yourself. Be yourself. Be yourself. You
cowards. Hundreds of men against a
woman. A a me. Look at that. Look at
her. And then one of them is throwing
things at her. kicking the clock. Come
on. Do you know what's worse? None of
them are saying no good man is coming
from them and saying stop this. Yeah.
Yeah. None, bro. None of them are like
if this was a pro Palestinian thing and
there was a mob of Muslim men doing
that. There will be at least a group of
others saying what the hell are you
doing? Yeah, exactly. And then there's
be a group of other people say what you
we're not saying that this is not this
doesn't happen, but it's inconce I've
never seen this happen actually where no
one is intervening and no one is saying
anything. I've never seen it. Exactly.
They're sick people. Um sadly but yeah
till next time brother and sistersam
alaikum.